large online platforms should no longer
be able to earn money by using
journalists and artist content without
paying them fairly that's the crux of a
new agreement on copyright rules
crucially startups and smaller online
platforms will be subject to lighter
obligations than more established
household names like YouTube or Facebook
if you don't have the 10 million global
turns over or if you have not more than
5 million unique monthly visitors then
you are a little bit exempted of these
articles 13 article 13 would make online
platforms liable for copyright
infringing content uploaded to them the
end result of this is that platforms
will compensate authors more fairly for
their work there is no requirement for
platforms to put filters in place it
will be up to the platform to decide how
they implement the rules news
aggregators will still be able to use
snippets of articles or footage of
events as is currently the case provided
the snippet is only a very short extract
and don't worry your memes are safe the
uploading of works for parody pastiche
criticism or quotations and now
specifically protected thanks to this
law freedom of expression is not touched
if you need a kind of a fundament like a
copyright protected work and you are
changing it somehow yes you have the
right to upload this also to the
platform's the directive enhances the
power of creatives who can negotiate
better remuneration for their work used
digitally
you